and i've been
talking about the diet not because i
wanted to be
known as a diet person because i was
never really interested in like vegan or
gluten-free or any of that it was just
like i'm more interested in books you
know and stories and
learning things than diet
but i've felt
like the urge to tell people about this
because of how much i suffered and how
much of a difference it made to me that
i've felt like morally obligated to tell
people even though i don't really enjoy
being the diet person
[Music]
welcome to episode 147 of my podcast the
michaela peterson podcast sorry about
the lack of episode last week i got a
toddler flu and almost died
what you're about to see is a
conversation that's actually from dr
mark goldston's podcast so i'm the
interviewee for a change he was on my
podcast last summer mark's an incredibly
kind ex-fbi hostage negotiator
psychiatrist and the author or co-author
of nine books
he's also well known for coaching ceos
and as the inventor of surgical empathy
we've been trying to make this happen
for a while now and i'm glad we did
because we covered a lot of interesting
topics i hope
we talked about purpose my experience
with psychedelics and the difference
between coping and healing we also
explored some interesting concepts like
surgical empathy and how ayahuasca seems
to reconfigure minds
before we get started this episode was
sponsored by bio-optimizers if you're
experiencing anxiety depression stress
or have trouble sleeping having a
routine can make or break you but
there's a super easy to implement thing
most of us forget about magnesium 50 of
americans are magnesium deficient
seriously isn't that insane
magnesium's proven to help with
depression anxiety diabetes blood sugar
blood pressure and even fat metabolism
and digestion as magnesium is the body's
master mineral and powers over 300
critical reactions and again
50 percent of americans are deficient
magnesium breakthrough by bio optimizers
is a supplement with all seven organic
forms of magnesium and cofactors like
manganese and vitamin b6 for enhanced
stress relief and performance
many users report immediately noticing
the benefits most magnesium supplements
are synthetic or only have a couple of
types of magnesium in them magnesium
breakthrough is the only supplement like
this on the market make it a habit be in
charge of your well-being just take one
before bed every night and see how you
feel the next day
there's an exclusive offer to get you
started
visit
magbreakthrough.com
peterson or use code peterson at
checkout for 10 off
mother's day is coming up too just
saying
enjoy this episode
[Music]
welcome to another episode of my wake-up
call this is that podcast where i meet
people i get to know a little bit about
them and i want to get to know a lot
more about them but while i'm getting to
know them i figure why don't you listen
in our listeners
and then when my guests
use videos why don't you
watch as we get to know each other
and i'm really excited
to
uh
have as my guest the ever elusive
michaela peterson because i was on her
podcast
and we've been meaning to connect
and because of all kinds of
various things
we didn't connect until now but let me
tell you a little bit about her
she's an amazing podcaster
she's a ceo tedx and oxford union
speaker she's the host of the michaela
peterson podcast where she interviews a
wide range of experts and public figures
to discuss health
natural phenomena politics and other
topics that are often shied away from
by the way she overcame incredible
adversity in the form of severe
autoimmune diseases that destroyed her
ankle hip and brain function
after researching and implementing a new
diet for which she is now known
she is also the founder of the lion diet
michaela
good to see you again
cool good to see you too thanks for
having me on
thank you so let me ask you if you were
to
think of the through line a consistency
in your life
a kind of a fill in the blanks i've
always
blah blah blah blah
and then if you can also think of your
purpose
or calling
why you are here on this planet
and share with us what those are
and then tell us the story of how you
developed them
uh and let's have a conversation
okay
so i think if i had to recognize a
pattern about how i behaved throughout
my life
i had a fair i had a very rough time
being sick as a kid with juvenile
rheumatoid arthritis
and i think partly because of how i was
raised
i was always i was never going to be
overcome by it you know i didn't
i would
i refused to give up right
and i harnessed some sort of anger
within myself in order to push back and
i think
probably a lot of people with chronic
diseases that are fighting them
they probably understand what i mean but
i was like this isn't gonna be what
takes me out so i had a lot of doctors
throughout my life say
you're gonna have this forever um you're
gonna be on these medications forever
you're not gonna be able to have kids
right um you're gonna die young just
statistically you know
and
at some point
i think i i was probably
it was probably fairly young maybe when
i was 12 i was just like no that's not
i'm not i'm not listening to that that's
not what's happening and that kind of
grew in intensity until i was about 23
and it was really i would
probably describe it as anger of like
that's not how i'm letting my kind of
life narrative play out i'm not going to
be the sick person um so i would say
that's probably
a pattern like the biggest pattern
throughout my life was being able to
harness this type of like i don't know
anger and stubbornness
um and that's manifested more recently
in
in ways where you know with work i can
say okay i want something to go a
certain way and i don't really believe
in
glass walls or anything stopping me from
doing things i think that if you try as
hard as you can you can accomplish
incredible things and i think a lot of
people are stuck in
kind of fake boxes that they make for
themselves
right in these invisible structures
saying well that's not possible for me
because of x
and really none of that's real you you
can almost do you can almost do anything
which sounds crazy but i do believe that
um and then can you repeat your second
question i want to do this in the right
order well before we uh repeat that
i'm going to give you a new word that i
hope you like
are you open to that yes definitely
because
something that was built into me
was
it's not great to be judgmental you know
i was a therapist don't be judgmental
and as a result i think i could be
manipulated by people oh don't be
judgmental oh they have an issue
and what's happened is i've gotten older
i've replaced the word judgmental with
discerning
oh i like that i like the word
discerning i can be discerning
and i'm not being judgmental so you
mention the words angery and stubborn
both of which can be triggering to other
people like ah
she's going to be high maintenance and
i'd like you to replace both those words
with determined
hmm i became very determined
that nothing was going to stop me
okay i can get behind that it was
determination it just had a
like uh
it had a it was serious determination if
that's the case serious determination
like there's a wall and this is a
decision and this is what i'm doing so
yeah i could probably replace
anger i think i had so much negative
emotion when i was sick i don't have
that anymore now that i'm better but i
think i had so much negative emotion
when i was sick that it felt more like
it felt like if you're climbing up a
mountain and you have to really grit and
bear it and like
er up the mountain and so i equated that
with anger but i mean determination is
reasonable i can get behind that
okay it's just a suggestion you're also
this is a conversation you're also
reminding me
of someone and maybe you'll have her on
your podcast if we can locate her
there's a woman named anna i don't know
her
last name but i think she has a website
called anna runs america
and she ran across america for ow for
veterans charities and a friend of mine
interviewed her and he said
why didn't you give up
and she said as i was running
i kept imagining all the time that i was
a blind person seeing for the first time
wow
so when you're running
oh that's a palm tree uh i i must be in
the south uh well that's a mom-and-pop
uh business that's probably not gonna be
here in six months and
oh that was a saint bernard who left
that on the sidewalk in front of me i'd
better avoid that but just the idea of
imagining your blind seeing for the
first time
wow and
and i've actually and feel free to use
that with audiences by the way because a
lot of times we have to do something to
overcome zoom fatigue and a lot of
people throw in all kinds of
pyrotechnics and something you're
welcome to use which i've used because i
i believe those things can be
you know kind of stimulating but
distracting but an exercise i'll do and
you're welcome to do it i'll say i have
a couple exercises
one is i want you to close your eyes for
30 seconds
and when you open them imagine you're a
blind person seeing for the first time
and and when you open them notice stuff
that you didn't notice
notice the person next to you notice the
back of their head
notice uh you know one of their shirt
collar if you're in a zoom call notice
the person in the square next to you
notice their background because when you
notice you're more present than just
looking watching and seeing
and now what i'd like you to do but you
won't be able to hear my instruction and
you know what i'm going to say is i want
you to cover your ears
and
and then
we'll cover them for 15 seconds
and count inside your own head to 15
and then when you uncover your ears
imagine that you're a deaf person
listening for the first time
and then the final one because sometimes
i'll give presentations about emotional
intelligence
and i'll and that's a feeling
close your eyes
cover your ears
and when you open them
i want you to imagine that you're
feeling for the first time
see if you can feel into the room
is there a level of stress
is there a level of zoom fatigue is
there a level of whatever
but but do you follow what i'm saying
it's a way for
helping them use what's already in there
to focus them so
uh
anyway i wanted to share that with you
because it's it's
i think it helps us
to quickly feel alive
i think that's a good trick it's
probably good when you're doing
kind of monotonous household tasks to
learn how to appreciate those things
it's not so bad it's a lot better than
suffering actively
yeah absolutely so so by getting back to
you
uh we talked about the through line and
then i wanted
you to speak about what you feel your
purpose and calling in life is
and what it is that
you're here for
and what it is that you want to give to
the world
and how you want to leave the world uh
after they've
been involved with you
okay well i i actually do have an answer
to that
so
uh
i
i had a massive transformation with
dietary change right i went from
almost dying from dying like really
um hip replaced ankle replaced on like
seven medications trying to keep me
awake some to help me sleep immune
suppressants puffers like antihistamines
just to like live
i um antidepressants
uh painkillers
it was bad
and those were all prescribed just just
to manage symptoms and i completely
changed my life
with diet which is something that
matters i mean it was complicated like
i've been only eating ruminant meat like
beef and lamb since 2017
something that people didn't think that
you'd be able to do
and so it's not
it's not that
it's not that shocking that the medical
community wasn't like hey you should try
an all meat diet because nobody thought
that um but i think because of the
transformation it made for me so i'm in
remission i'm off of medications and the
only time i have autoimmune flare-ups
are if i eat something wrong or if i
catch a virus
other than that i'm asymptomatic and
i've been
talking about the diet not because i
wanted to be
known as a diet person because i was
never really interested in like vegan or
gluten-free or any of that it was just
like i'm more interested in books you
know and stories and
learning things than diet
but i've felt
like the urge to tell people about this
because of how much i suffered and how
much of a difference it made to me that
i've felt like morally obligated to tell
people even though i don't really enjoy
being the diet person so tell us about
your discovering the power and what you
really like most about podcasting
i really like people like i kind of i
kind of also don't like people
it's like i don't like people but i also
find people really interesting
i find the different way people think
very interesting so i've been doing this
segment so i'll interview people so i
interviewed you and had you on that was
a great podcast
but i also do something called opposing
views so i'll talk about a subject that
people really
have
extreme emotions about so something like
abortion
and i'll bring somebody on who has
really extreme emotions that's pro-life
someone who has really extreme emotions
is pro-choice
and
i don't talk to them together because
that would be a disaster right but i'll
ask them the same questions and just
have two separate conversations and then
show people the difference in the
responses and i just find it
unbelievably interesting again i think
in the last number of years our
societies split so badly it's so
fragmented that there are people on the
right and people on the left that think
the other side's evil like stupid and
evil
right and
that doesn't quite make sense so i've
been trying to bridge the gap being like
look how
you know look how both of these people
can kind of look reasonable but have
completely the opposite views and it
isn't that interesting so i think i like
i think i like podcasting because i'm
able to talk to a lot of people it's
also like i'm lucky i can talk to
anybody basically i can't talk to anyone
but i can talk to
experts in fields that i would never be
able to get to otherwise right like when
i was trying to research health things i
was like well who's a
you know toxic mold specialist
and then instead of waiting three months
to talk to someone i can just say do you
want to come on the podcast which is
like sneaky maybe a little bit selfish
but i figure other people are interested
in the same things so it's just i love
it it's crazy to be able to make money
off of having conversations with people
it's crazy
can i share something with you about
because you triggered in me
my
sensitivity and awareness to the
divisiveness and
and why people so adamantly
hold on to points of view can i share
with you my latest thinking on it oh
definitely
so my latest thinking is that
people develop psychological adhesions
which is different than a psychological
attachment
okay
because if you go into if you need
surgery
surgery that saves your life
you may be the surgery may be saving
your life but your inner body is not
used to being invaded so after the
surgery is over you can sometimes
develop adhesions between the organs
that can
uh that people have to go in
and surgically excise
and i've also developed something we
even talked about it on your podcast
surgical empathy
and i think what happens is
when people develop psychological
adhesions
reason cannot get through
because it's an adhesion
if it's a psychological attachment
you may be able to sort of share with
them
reasoning steps
and they may be able to take that in but
i think the greater the stress in the
world
the more that people grab onto something
and it's like an adhesion
i also gave a talk to saudi arabia about
seven years ago
on overcoming resistance to change
and my central hypothesis
is resistance to change doesn't exist
and i said what exists see if you can
feel this
what exists is
non-rational non-functional
self-preservation
non-rational non-functional
self-preservation
and if you think of people's minds
as a silo like a silo a grain silo and
on the top is competence
underneath that is confidence
and underneath that is control
so the narrower your competence
but that the world loves
and will pay you billions of dollars
like some of our tech ceos
they're laying
and you can think of elon musk and you
can think of bezos think of steve jobs
it's i am competent here i am confident
i am in control
and they will try to pull the world into
that silo
because it works for them
but the problem is it doesn't work most
other places
they're not capable of getting
emotionally close to anyone
people do not feel intimate with them
and they can't feel intimate to others
but because they have that
lane that the world says i love my tesla
i love going on amazon
the world rewards them
but they live in this psychological silo
and i believe they have psycho
psychological adhesions
but when they're rewarded so well
they get away with it
but try to be married to one of those
people
uh and try to have something other than
a conversation that fits in how they
uh how they grock the world
forget about it so i think if you look
at people
uh and i won't get into politics but you
can think of some of the
top paul leaders who are
running amok
i think they have psychological
adhesions
you can't you can't reason with them
in their mind they're right
and one of the things they cannot stand
more than anything is humiliation
so one of my missions in life is
is to
have the world
have more women leaders
because one of the things that
distinguishes women from men
is some of the male leaders that we see
can't stand humiliation
and they will do anything to avoid
humiliation
even destroy the world
whereas women who have children are
humiliated every day
you're walking around and your kid just
won't shut up in the middle of a thing
and you get those looks can't you quiet
your kid
and and i think
anyway i don't want to get off on a
tangent but i just want to share that
with you and have you think about it
psychological adhesions
and and unfortunately if they don't
listen to reason
that's why you have to go in
militarily uh for me with my suicidal
patients
they had a psychological adhesion to
dying ah if i just died the pain will go
away
ah dying feels like it'll just relieve
everything
where surgical empathy would go in
and if people would feel felt kind of a
little bit like you did in our podcast
with you
when people feel felt there's a little
fluidity and they can sometimes let go
of their adhesion to death is the only
way out
so did any of that make sense i know i
kind of made it
more my uh
my content than yours but this is a
conversation
no no it does it does make sense um i
think that
i think you're right about people
adhering to an idea um
as some sort of not entirely sure i
can't remember exactly how you put it
but it kind of a safety mechanism like
survival right and that's why because
when you look at some of these people
with
kind of ideological ideas or just really
stuck to one idea and unable to listen
it does kind of seem like
it's an animal in survival mode right
where it's like nope i'm not going there
i refuse to listen and i'm not listening
i can't go there i think i honestly
think i used to be like that more
um when i was a and i was younger and i
was sicker and i was on medication and
you know there's all that but when
people
um
when people suggested this really sticks
with me because i changed so much but
when people suggested that i look into
alternative routes from
for my medical problems
i pretty much just shut them down and it
was kind of because it would be
insulting right it was like well have
you tried diet and i was like how dare
you like i just had my hip replaced have
i tried diet right so there's a way to
to kind of have those conversations
without being condescending but i do
remember times when i went to
naturopaths and some of them said hey i
think you know you should cut out gluten
gluten is going to be a problem and i
was so stuck to
uh the medical community because i think
i'd been in it for so long my dad's very
science focused and i was like no that's
the scientific way
there is no other way i was really stuck
to it and
i ended up
looking into diet because i spent
from the ages of like 19 to 22 and i
just ramped up and up and up reading and
reading and reading scientific papers
and those scientific papers led me to
gluten being a potential problem for
people with autoimmunity and so i went
to diet the scientific route
and then when i realized the medical
system had missed some of these
scientific papers
um then like my entire world exploded
like it really exploded when i went on
the diet and was like this isn't going
to work i just went on a very very low
carb diet so it was like meat and greens
and it made a massive difference in a
month to severe crippling like i had
arthritis everywhere except for my spine
and it was like a month in and i felt
significantly better
and my entire world view fell apart
so i went from
firmly believing like i used to argue
with people in class about beliefs you
know i was the on facebook arguing with
people
uh debating and when i lost faith in
when i was like no the medical community
missed something i was like well what
else what else am i believing in
really strongly that's missed something
and then for a couple of years i didn't
have faith in anything so it was like
well the government do they know what
they're doing
like do police officers know what
they're doing you know any figure any
authority figure i was just like are
they real though
right and then i suppose you do get
older and you're like well everyone's
a person whether or not they're in a
figure of authority we're all just
people
so i think growing up had something to
do with that but
i'd say maybe people who have this kind
of adhesion mindset
haven't had their belief systems just
shattered
right because i'm pretty disagreeable
i'm pretty stubborn and i think i was
like that before i had my belief system
shattered and it happened a couple of
times it happened when i first tried
diet which was just like a very very
limited paleo diet then it happened
again when i went to just meat and was
like
people can survive off of only eating
meat i thought you were gonna die of
scurvy i thought i was gonna get vitamin
deficient i was like what
what is going on what's real out there
and then i suppose too when my dad
started showing up in the media as this
evil
alt-right character
i was like well that's not my dad like
that's not right either like is the
media lying like is anybody telling the
truth
so
i don't know what was what was it like
when you
went through that period of a couple
years when you couldn't believe anything
you know that you were hearing that that
everything was suspect and and the more
they claimed to be in authority the more
cynical you were about you know you know
what what's their ulterior motive what
was that like to not be able to believe
anything
it was pretty scary i was like
it also coincided when i um i stopped
taking all my medication when my
symptoms started to go away and i ended
up in extremely severe ssri withdrawal
so it's hard to differentiate between my
belief systems shattering and the ssri
withdrawal which caused it's
unbelievable
excruciating anxiety and depression so
it's hard to separate them but for
a number of years
i was pretty scared and um
i googled a lot i spent a lot of time
reading and if anybody like anybody
it was very bad at a certain point if
anybody said anything they're like you
know walking down the street i'd have a
friend say oh this building's this
building's old it's like from 1936. i
was like
is it
google that so i don't know how
enjoyable i was to be around but i did
it to
everybody um i did it to like friends
did it too
dates i went on did it to my dad like
anybody said anything factual and i was
like is that even true
and it turns out if you google people
a lot of it's not true a lot of what
people say just they're just saying
things they've heard
or that their parents have told them and
it's not true so what was it like it was
scary and time consuming and a lot of
googling i don't do that as much anymore
but i'm still skeptical
this episode is brought to you by
nordvpn nordvpn hides your ip and lets
you access forbidden parts of the
internet want to buy research chemicals
from china
nordvpn
i'm kidding don't do that
listeners outside the us know how much
bigger the netflix catalog is here
or if they don't now they do it's bigger
here
suckers now i'm in america and this
immigrant can access your netflix
but while traveling or in sketchy areas
i still do use nordvpn you probably know
nordvpn's the fastest vpn in the world
it doesn't buffer or crash like others
i've used but you may not know all the
ways it can protect you too
phishing sites or malware sites for
example are only getting better even
companies like facebook meta not
facebook twitch or linkedin get hacked
routinely those of you who've manually
changed passwords over a dozen accounts
understand the pain nordvpn works across
all your devices to protect you from all
those threats and more
they're hands down the best vpn in the
game
and i've been using vpns for years if
you haven't tried them already now is
the time to start
take advantage of my exclusive limited
time offer today
and see what full online protection
really feels like grab your nordvpn deal
today over at nordvpn.com
tmpp
or use promo code tmpp for 61 off their
premium plan
and their free anti-malware feature all
with nordvpn's 30-day money-back
guarantee that's only at nordvpn.com
tmpp or promo code tmpp which is the
acronym for this podcast enjoy the rest
of this episode
let me share something with you and tell
me is it okay if i because you trigger
things in me that i want to share is
that all right yeah yeah of course
conversational
and
for some reason rather i am drawn to
things
that are
um
counter-intuitive meaning i never would
have thought of it that way
but intuitively correct
i think that would work
you know so the so the psychological
adhesions
a lot of people would say i never would
have thought of it that way but
that's probably true the reason they're
not open is it's not an attachment where
you can reason your way through it's an
adhesion you know it's like
they're internally it's an adhesion
so
uh
part of what
uh
you would just
uh triggering with me
and uh
in sharing
what you've been sharing
is uh i wrote a book during the pandemic
called why cope when you can heal
and when i ask people especially women
who were somewhat in touch with their
feelings
thinking of writing a book co-authoring
a book called why cope when you can heal
they'd stop me and they'd say if only
and i'd say if only what
they said if only i could heal
and i'd say what do you mean
they say i cope
what do you mean
well coping is better than not coping
but i i'm not free i
i don't feel peace i'm exhausted
i don't feel joy i have fun
and then when you say to them do you
think you could get through it again
many of them will look at you flat out
there in the headlights i don't know how
i made it through the first time i don't
know why it didn't take me down i don't
think i could do it again
and so one of the things we talk about
in the book
and this is what i
tell me if this is counter-intuitive
uh and i think some of it was coming out
this is why i was drilling down to your
two years of not being leaving any
anyone
so i believe that when we're traumatized
we develop something called the horror
terror
don't panic trifecta
so something is horrifying the world
doesn't know what to do with me
it's not going away i'm terrified i
can't take it anymore don't panic
because if you panic you're gonna you're
gonna freeze you're gonna paralyze you
won't even be able to communicate to
people you know so what happens is we do
everything we can to push that away
and something that often enables us to
push it away
is
adrenaline and also testosterone so what
happens is veterans
to push it away the horror the terror
don't panic
they push it away
and superficially they have a veneer of
feeling i'm superhuman
geez i didn't think i could make it
through the next shift and i i'm a
healthcare worker i've just been up for
48 hours that's pretty cool but inside
you know something's messed up
and the danger
and the adrenaline and testosterone
which allows you to make it through
you realize there's going to be hell to
pay when the danger goes away
so i think veterans and i think
healthcare workers
are going to uh when the danger goes
away all the stuff they pushed inside in
a way to survive
what we're calling the horror the terror
don't panic
because you got to function
is going to come up and threaten to rip
them apart
and part of what needs
and that's why we call it surgical
empathy part of what they need is to
safely
allow
themselves to experience and feel
what they could when they were surviving
i believe ayahuasca and psychedelics
work because often people now they're
people who use it recreationally but the
people who use it therapeutically
they're often control freaks
but they're being control freaks is not
working for them anymore
it's uh uh
but they can't let go of control because
they don't trust anyone and if they let
go of control they're gonna panic
they're gonna shatter
and so i think what the psychedelics and
ayahuasca do
is it's a
it's a sort of controlled therapeutic
psychosis
you're going to go in and you're
definitely going to be out of control
and we're going to walk you through you
the throwing up is part of it you know
everybody throws up and what's happening
is your mind is
deconfiguring
because it wasn't working the way it's
working
and i use the metaphor because i'm
trying to create
something called guaranteed to blow your
mind
how ayahuasca works
and the idea is
if you think of our mind when we're born
is a rubric's cube and think of it being
in the wrapper and it's pristine
and then life messes it up
and we solve it so it looks like it's in
the wrapper
but as life gets complicated
the way it looks in the wrapper doesn't
work anymore
you know life on the outside is
different than life inside a womb
and if you keep trying to solve it for
how it is in the wrapper is not working
anymore
and so i think what ayahuasca and
psychedelics do
is they scramble up that rubric's cube
but when they solve it it's a different
design than it was in the wrapper
and it's a design
that you can lean into
in your life
is this making any sense to you
i think so i've done quite a few
psychedelics i'm not entirely sure how
to think about psychedelics like i
almost think about them as
connecting you to a spiritual level as
well absolutely
like yeah they're pretty they're pretty
wild and they can be extremely helpful
for um
trauma if you're
ready to kind of delve into it right if
you're if you're get if you get to the
head space where you're like okay okay
for instance when i was going through
that whole thing and in really bad shape
after i figured diet out and then went
off of medications and then just waited
to get better
um
i didn't do
psychedelics for a number of years
because i was like i cannot
adding that into the mix right now like
that could go down a really
negative route
and yeah you don't want to have like i
mean some people have bad trips and then
they end up better afterwards like even
if it was a negative experience but at
that point i was like with especially
with ssri withdrawals like i can't risk
it it's too scary
um and it wasn't until i
was in a better space i actually felt
better i'm not saying this works for
everyone but i felt like stable enough
and i was like okay there's some
trauma really and there's some parts of
myself that i might be hiding that i
really need to sort out because you can
like manipulate yourself in all sorts of
ways and like hide little parts of
yourself
away so you don't see them and i was
like i want to make sure everything's
out in the open
and i did a number of pretty heavy dose
mushroom trips and it was incredibly
beneficial to me
i think again i don't think there was
any
negative downside
and i think i was able to sort through
some
problems that would have stayed hidden
for a long time
psychedelics are really wild i think
that they they definitely need to be
used in a therapeutic setting
and people need to do more research so
as you remember
tell me if this fits your trip because
i've been trying to
explain it to people in a way
so that you there may be a way to do it
without the mushrooms
but
can
can you relate to this that you you took
them you were in a in a more of a mental
healthy
less fragile state than you'd been
before so you knew that and what
happened is
uh
in the middle of it your mind as you
know it
it's almost like it
it
uh decoupled the things that you
believed uh that you you were adamant
about you weren't so adamant about but
it was okay and things just started
being loose
uh and but you were somehow okay because
you were mentally healthy enough to not
go off the deep end and never come back
and what happens is
they they were they were loose but then
when they came back together again
here's the metaphor i remember
someone i know
came in
uh
and and she said this is what
psychedelics did for me
she said psychedelics work like a
plumber
and i said what do you mean
and she said
my mind is like plumbing
that works but it doesn't flow it's like
my mind is jammed together and i make it
through life but it doesn't flow
and psychedelics rip out the plumbing
and then the plumbing gets reassembled
organically
from a place that's more
organically cohesive inside yourself
and when you come out
the water flows
but before the trip uh if you haven't
had psychotic breaks and you weren't
thrown in hospitals
uh it's like your mind is plumbing but
it just it just doesn't work it creaks
it's
and and maybe it was assembled because
of childhood trauma or who knows what or
disbelief and authority figures
but the psychedelics rips up the
plumbing
and then reassembles it in a natural way
and you can just exhale
and feel like life's going to be okay
without having to make sure that you
make it okay
yeah okay i like that i think i agree
i agree with most of that
i definitely agree with the feeling that
it gives you afterwards that you don't
have to control everything that things
are just going to work out like it
really does
uh it really does leave you with a sense
of
i don't have to control everything and
almost like god's will
but
psychedelics
so i i definitely had had that and then
for reorganizing
yeah i mean i've like i said i've had
really positive experiences with it like
for me i they made me at that time they
made me more loving
so i had more empathy towards other
people so there were people that i was
like this person is kind of annoying
right because there are people that are
like you don't get along with very well
like that person's kind of annoying or i
don't like that person and it's not like
i was like actively
mean but i had one experience where
i saw every relationship in my entire
life and how i was contributing
negatively to each of those
relationships
i was like
oh
i'm doing that like i'm contributing
negatively into the world that way
and it wasn't even judgmental like
that's the that was the interesting
thing it wasn't you're a bad person for
doing for acting that way it was
more kind it was like here's how you're
acting badly towards other people um
that's wrong
and then i was just like well i'll just
stop then
and so it was just like pretty simple it
was like i didn't know that i feel
really bad that i was contributing
negatively to some of these
relationships and i'll stop now and i'm
sorry and then it was
you know forgiveness and
they're they're just they're crazy
so
here's another word to throw into the
mix that i'm hearing
just like i gave you the word uh
determination
i i think a non-mental health word is
impatient
i was exceeding when i was annoyed i'd
be impatient
and something about it enabled me to be
more patient i didn't have they didn't
have to agree with me they didn't they
didn't have to fit a category they
they could just be different from the
way i see it and i was just more patient
with it whereas before
it's almost like if it didn't fit a
certain kind of pattern or belief i got
annoyed
but i was able to kind of
just let it let them be
the way it is oh i like that i like that
okay determined
determined and more patient
it is it's actually more accurate too
because it really is that is getting
frustrated or you're talking to somebody
you're like why don't they understand
things the way i understand them you
know what's going on there and it is
really patience
i like that so here so so here's
something you're going to do in one of
your podcasts okay um
and because it's such a good podcast
see if you can get paul mccartney on
oh
no way well no partner but part of what
you're going to do
and maybe you can leverage your dad
is we want to have you on or you can say
this is you paul i want to have you on
because you the beatles did a song
called let it be
speaking words of wisdom let it be yeah
and i'm discovering
that that's
what i'm learning to do and it's making
me a better person
and
we'll play the song
and let's have a conversation about it
because it seems like the more people
are trying to control other people
the worse the relationships are
and so listen to the song
see if it resonates with you and then
then you know you call all your leverage
cards i think you could pull it
off in fact i know someone uh i could
get an introduction to him i believe if
you can't get one yourself
okay okay well i'd be interested in that
let it be that's a great song i'm all
for that yeah listen to it listen to it
so i something something i sometimes do
i did this when i had your dad on the
podcast
is i sometimes speak to my listeners
who will listen to this podcast
if you're listening to this
we're watching it if if we put up video
excerpts
very much like
her father
michaela is not trying to be controlling
her intentions are not to run over you
what she's saying is hey i've got kind
of a
i've had kind of a traumatic life and
i've been searching
for ways that will work for me
and
and the search
put me
looking at things differently than
conventional ways
but it worked for me and so i wrote it
up
but uh i'm not here
to tell you uh
i'm a know-it-all and you don't know
what you're talking about i'm just
saying
you know life's been pretty challenging
and when i tried to solve it
following conventional approaches i
didn't get much relief
and what i'm discovering is how i got
relief
and it seems that i have a platform so
i'm sharing with you how i got that
relief
you know i put it into a book
i'm not saying you're wrong if you eat
whatever you're eating
i'm just wanting to share it
and and i remember when your dad was on
my podcast
one of the things i pointed out to my
listeners
he's not saying empathy is bad
what he's saying is to just
be give unconditional empathy that
everything your child does is wonderful
is setting them up to fail
yeah
you know uh you know and you don't want
to set them up to fail
but if you make everything they do
wonderful they can't learn
and the world's not going to treat them
that way
and don't do that but but of course you
know listeners will take something
and they will run with it the wrong way
so please if you're listening to this
we listen to when i had
michaela's father jordan peterson on
because
their intentions
are to help the world
they don't have the intent they don't
wake up saying how can i make the world
worse
it's the opposite
and just like michaela understood after
she did
some psychedelics and some work
huh i might be seeing
the world
not the way it is i i might be impatient
i might be a little bit unforgiving
i may be running into people who are
actually forgivable but i have an
unforgiving streak
and my unforgiving streak you know
sometimes screws things up you know i
gotta do something about that so please
if you're listening in
[Music]
know that her intentions
match her behavior a lot of times people
have intentions
and then people and people misread their
behavior but i think your intentions and
the intentions of your dad are great
so
well
no the world
the world i wouldn't say the world needs
to know more about you because they know
a lot about you
but they need to see you through the
lens of your wanting to be helpful
as opposed to you're just
gratuitously wanting to stir the pot
yes
i don't want to stir the pot i don't
particularly mind controversy so i'm not
adverse to stirring the pot but no i
just want people to not suffer as much
as they do
life is so hard
like if you're not actively suffering
you should just rejoice just party it up
that day
like yay i'm not suffering today and so
any way to reduce that amount of
suffering
that's what dad's trying to do too and
he does talk about how empathy he like
he does sometimes get quoted as saying
empathy is bad but he's
so compassionate it's crazy like when he
has people come up to him on the street
saying you know your work has helped me
he'll just cry
like he because he feels things like so
it's definitely not about controversy
it's definitely not about controversy
it's about trying to you know do what
you think will reduce suffering in the
world
and i think you're doing it well thank
you thank you so the best place for
people to find out more about you is
uh youtube probably my podcast so you
can type in michaela peterson and that's
m i k h a i l a peterson on youtube and
then i'm on instagram same thing
michaela peterson and i have a website
mikaylapeterson.com and if people are
interested in the diet i have lion
diet.com and everything on there is free
and it's just
information about what i've learned and
how i put myself into remission so
that's where you can find me
i love that i love that um so thank you
for listening in thank you for our
finally finding the time um
i'm at your service if i can ever be of
any help
and that goes to you my listeners
and
thank you for
subscribing that seems to help and do
write reviews at apple podcasts tell us
how we can do an even better job if if
we're not
uh if we're not connecting with you tell
us how we can connect even better
and until next time everybody take care
take care of yourself and be be kind to
everyone
[Music]
you